it is the feature film adaptation of
Stephen King's famous book we already
had a 1990 miniseries starring Tim Curry
based off of that book and now we get to
see it in theaters and here we have a
bunch of kids who are part of the losers
Club a bunch of unpopular kids who band
together in Derry Maine to fight against
Pennywise the dancing clown a demonic
entity that feeds off of their fear
before I get into the film a lot of
people have asked me what I think of the
1990 Tim Curry it the first half is
pretty good I think the kids are great
in the movie the second half I'm just
gonna say it it sucks it even the
director doesn't like it look it up the
director of it doesn't even like the
second part it just goes completely off
the rails and I think it's one of those
adaptations that kind of lives in your
memory as something that affected you a
lot maybe the first time you saw it it's
sort of this pop-culture icon that we
all remember Tim Curry as penny wise and
he is really good in it I love Tim Curry
in that miniseries but I just actually
rewatched it a couple weeks ago and I
don't really think it holds up that's
just my opinion of the miniseries the
film however whoa that's a different
story
I pretty much loved everything about
this movie the movie does justice to the
greatest strengths of the novel and
wisely omits
parts of the novel that didn't work my
biggest discrepancy with the novel was
Beverly marshes decision to please all
of her young friends if you've read the
book you know what I'm talking about
that was just a gigantic WTF moment that
didn't really work for me
it wasn't in the miniseries but what
didn't work for me about that miniseries
was the adult aspect of it when you got
to see them as adults coming back to
Derry Maine this film just focuses on
them in their young lives dealing with
the things they're most afraid of and it
wisely doesn't spend too much time with
each character unless it has something
directly to do with their fear you don't
really learn much about their home lives
unless their home lives is integral to
learning about what they're afraid of
this is important for the Beverley
character in particular because her home
life is awful and so we get to see a lot
more of that but with each kid they just
focus on whatever they're most afraid of
whether it's germs or the way they're
inside or the way their brother died
they try to find the things that scare
them the most whatever smells like the
most tasty bait for Pennywise because
that's what draws him in that's what
draws him out of the shadows let's talk
about the kids in this movie and the
performers across the board they are
phenomenal
it's always kind of hard and a little
awkward to hate on kids performing in
movies but gratefully I don't have to
they're all really strong since there
are a bunch of kids that have deemed
themselves the losers Club there's a
very underdog feel to them since there
are a bunch of kids who are fighting
against something that they can't
control and they don't fully understand
it reminded me of the kids in et when
they fought against the government or
the kids and stranger things when they
fought against the government but here
they're trying to go up against
something that no one else will believe
because when you're a kid you often feel
like the whole world is out to get you
and no adult is going to believe you if
you were to tell them I just saw a
murderous demonic clown in my kitchen
sink can you please help me and to top
it off the clown won't show himself to
people unless he wants to be seen so
that makes it even harder for them to
get any outside help so they are very
much so on their own and that really
gives the film an underdog team spirit
and all of the actors did an amazing job
but it all really does come down to that
clown doesn't it whether or not
Pennywise really works in the movie is
he unintentionally hilarious
or is he terrifying bill skarsgård as
penny wise is very scary here I haven't
seen a film that really truly terrified
me in many years but I have seen a lot
of very suspenseful and enjoyable films
this film is a very creepy
haunted house like experience where it
feels like things are going to pop out
of you every other scene there are very
few doll scenes we go from kids seeing
horrific to more kids seeing
horrific and there's never really a
moment to breathe you get your scenes
where kids are sitting down talking but
it's always about the plot it's always
about this clown and he really does work
bill skarsgård is excellent in the
shadow of Tim Curry who is easily the
best part of that miniseries and he
really pulled it off the makeup and the
CGI work that has been done to create
Pennywise really brought him into the
year 2017
I didn't find it funny at all in fact I
was smiling quite often at how
off-putting he was his voice the way
they edited around his body
they also found compelling ways to make
the CG seamless enough to where you
weren't like oh that's a special effect
image it didn't really feel that way
good performances good creepy villain
really fun characters the best part of
the book and the miniseries in my
opinion were the kids and this whole
film is focused on them if this director
who by the way does a fantastic job with
this film it looks awesome
the editing is so good all the creepy
scares are really well set up if he
decides to make a second one which it's
looking like he might I am there and
that's coming from somebody who really
doesn't give a about the adult part
of the it storyline I'm gonna give it an
A - this is a damn good Stephen King
adaptation I had a blast with it please
do check out my other Stephen King
reviews as well as my buddy skipper
Martin and Christopher de Filippis and
their podcast the Castle Rock TV podcast
every week they're going to thoroughly
explore all of the Castle Rock stories
and movies connected to the new upcoming
Hulu show leading to the premiere of
this series next year they just finished
delving deep into the behemoth novel it
they're now heading to the 1990 Tim
Curry miniseries and wrapping it up with
the new feature film they're gonna have
exclusive interviews with Stephen King
alumni beginning very soon with Cujo
star Dee Wallace if you're a big King
fan like I am and you're excited for
that new series that's being developed
with JJ Abrams check out this link and
subscribe to their podcasts on iTunes or
stitcher this is not sponsored skipper
Martin is a very good friend of mine and
I think that he is doing something
really cool that not enough people are
listening to and that's entirely why I'm
doing this for him I think that he is
definitely worth a listen if you're a
big fan of podcasts and King check that
out guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen iced
[Music]